coach Prime has made Colorado the hub
for viral moments this season and the
person capturing all these moments is
actually one of his own kids meet Deion
Sanders Jr his company well-off media
keeps the camera rolling at Colorado but
Dion JR originally had very different
career aspirations everyone thinks she
going to The League Junior was a wide
receiver and kick returner for the SMU
Mustang but after graduating at his
playing career not working out he put
his all into well-off media but it
wasn't easy for Dion Oh you're not Deion
Sanders you could get whatever you want
little do you know I'm struggling to pay
my rent yeah doubts about joining coach
Prime at Jackson State I said No at
first one conversation changed
everything after meeting with a
legendary rapper Jackson State got the
entire Sanders family on board bro it
would be crazy you go there with your
dad you do this like y'all starting your
own legacy on journey together the
office really 70 of the reason shador
went to Jackson State he's now behind
the camera in Colorado making it his
mission to show his family story that
includes appearances from the biggest
stars and from in-game moments that
aren't shown on TV neon Jr found his way
in his paying off showing the coach
Prime experience in Boulder through his
lens